hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar sars kovi ii specific b cell
detection and therapeutic antibody
discovery i am jennifer woods of lab
roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotek
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
christina conforti andrioni global
product manager for cell culture and
group leader in translational immunology
at miltoni biotech
christina you may now begin your
presentation
[Music]
so this is the agenda of the meeting i
would like to discuss about the role of
monitoring cellular immune response in
coffin 19 and also the recombinant sarc
of two proteins that we offer and how
they can be used for the b cell analysis
and finally uh i will end with the part
on the therapeutic antibody discovery
let's start with the monitoring of
cellular immune response
in general it is important to study the
immune response to viral infection
and indeed all immune cells can have a
role in the disease outcome and
clearance
some like for example macrophages
might have a negative role in the
pathogenesis of diseases such as
subscribe to
infection and kovin-19
and these cells can be studied as target
to develop drugs that can be used to
treat patients in an acute and severe
phase of the disease other cells like
lymphocytes placing state usually a
positive role in the defense against the
viruses
and also in the mounting of
immunological memory which gives the
protection from future infection
of course the goals of vaccination
against ascop2 as for any vaccination it
is to develop an immune response and
therefore measuring subscribe to
specific t-cells mb cells in vaccinated
individuals is a very important step in
the evaluation of the efficacy of copy
1919 vaccines
the most important difference between t
cells and b cells is that t cells
recognize
via t-cell receptor antigens bound to
the mhco-infected cells
on the contrary b cells via b-cell
receptor can recognize antigens of full
pathogens
present in the microenvironment without
the need of a presentation over an
infection
once the visas recognize the specific
antigen they develop into plasma cells
and the b cell receptor is basically an
antibody indirectly as plasma cells
is um released and secreted in the
environment and can eliminate the
pathogens in several ways
since the antibodies eliminate the
pathogens directly before the cells are
infected
this response is sometimes called
sterile immunity and it is usually the
target of vaccinations
how do antibody protect us
the most simple way an antibody can
protect us is via neutralization
in this in the case of subscribe to for
example some antibodies recognize the
protein spike
on the virus surface and block its
binding to the ac2 protein preventing
therefore the virus to infect the cells
of the body
there are however other ways that
antibodies can use to help to eliminate
immune response and to kill pathogens or
for example tumor cells
one example is the activation of the
complement
or the recruiting of killer immune cells
such as macrophages
or
end cases
as we will see later therapeutic
antibodies should be able to induce one
or more of these mechanisms and
therefore it is important also to test
the functionalities
so we have seen how basically a strong
antibody response per se should be able
to control and clear a viral infection
such as susque 2 infection
however it has been observed in several
individuals that the level of antibodies
in infected individuals go down after
several months after infection
and therefore these individuals are
still susceptible to future reinfection
with the virus
however a recent study have shown and
proved that b-cell instead persisted in
the blood or convalescence even over
eight months after infection and
therefore
a day the b cells could help to prevent
future infections or help the individual
to clear their virus quickly without
developing of a severe covid19
both rows of b and t cells are therefore
important in sask of two monitoring for
these reasons i mentally biotech we have
developed specific tools to study these
cells
in the following part of the webinar i
will illustrate the tools for suscroft
ii specific b-cell detection however for
t-cells we also have several products
and solution i can recommend in in order
to study the t-cell response to
saskatoon
you can find more of this information in
upcoming webinars and also in our
website
so let's look now at how to monitor uh
antigen-specific b-cells
using the sask of two proteins so in the
past 12 months i've been through the
biotech we have developed several
recombinant proteins of the sarcophagu
as you can see here all proteins are
manufactured in a recombinant eukaryotic
system
with or without equivalently bound
biotin
most of our tools have been developed to
recognize b cells specific for the spike
and the rbd receptor binding domain so
for the future data i will show you in
the next slide you will see
mainly these two proteins used and also
very importantly
we have a release and we are going to
release even in more in the future also
the newton variance of rbd and spike
how can you use this protein
the protein can be used to study
molecular mechanism of saskatoon virus
such as this binding of the spike
protein into the native s2 or fluorine
cleavage assays they can also be used to
detect antibodies in serum or plasma of
infected or vaccinated individuals
however one of the most important
application of the task of two
recombinant proteins is the study of the
sarcophagus b cells and specifically the
phenotyping and enrichment of this rare
population of cells and this is what i
will show you in the next slides
how does the system works so first of
all you need to create a so-called
tetramers using a simple protocol one
streptavidin conjugated to a fluorophore
can bind to four biotinylated
proteins such of two protein
by a short incubation at room
temperature for 15 minutes
then the tetramers are added to a cell
suspension of b cells
and the b cell specific for the vcr for
the spike or the rbd protein will bind
the tetramers via the bcr receptor
since the tetramers is conjugated by
streptavidin to the fluorochrome it is
then possible to detect the cells
and quantify them at the flow cytometer
you can check out the exact protocol for
determinization at our website
in all our experiment i will show you in
the next slide that we all started from
a pre-reached population of b cells
using a releasable system of the label
called realism
and specifically here we use
realist cd90 microbit kit which indeed
allows to enrich cd19 positive cells
which are in the blood the b cells
after the enrichment via magnetic
separation the beats and the labels so
the antibodies on the cell on the
markers are actually released via the
release system at its part of the
protocol and of the kit therefore what
we further use and experiment are label
free pieces
and this is also very important for two
reasons
first because cd19 is not so highly
expressed on b cells and tend to be
easily saturated by labels therefore
freeing up demarcus cd19 from any
binding helps a better staining
for further uh downstream application
like flow cytometry
the second reason is that if you want to
do enrichment via micro bits you need to
get rid of the bits on the on the b cell
so that you can further enrich
antigen-specific b cell with a second
magnetic labeling
it is also possible to use the same
system
to enrich the thus of 2b cells also
using micro bits as i show you but also
by assorting so i will show you these
two examples later
also very importantly it is also
possible to start directly from pbnc
without for enrichment but we strongly
recommend it because pre-enrichment help
you to have a much better resolution in
the flow cytometry and a higher and
better results in in the cell separation
so very importantly we have used two
type of tetramer for the same protein
so basically the tetramers we are
preparing two different uh fluorochromes
conjugation one in pe and one in p value
seven seven zero in this way is possible
to detect the antigen specific b cells
by getting on the diagonal
of the gate of the dot plot in this way
the unlabeled cells are excluded
here you can see the gating strategy by
excluding uh that cells and and doublet
and then by getting on the cd9 team
which is under all the b cells
and and then
further on the scatters
and then on the on the two levels
via the tetramers
furthermore
our panels also included int igg iga
and igm antibody that allows also to
further phenotype
the um
the isotypes and also cd27 to
distinguish their memory b cells
and also you can see here that we have
tested our system in kovid19
covalescence versus health in control
and as expected we saw that they held
the convalescent show
a persistence of b cells after three to
six months after infection and this was
much higher statistically compared to
the lt controls
and this proved that our system is
actually very specific for sask of 2.
as mentioned is also possible to enrich
the cells via sorting using the same
panel used for for
analysis here we have used the max1
title cell sorter
because in this way we could really
obtain a several advantages i will show
you in the next slide
as you see we obtain a very high purity
or sus positive b cells
and on the contrary of coursing at the
control was not possible to enrich the
cells because if we are really low
why to use the maxwell title in these
settings this is a perfect system to
sort in safety fragile and rare cells
it is indeed used in covenanted study
exactly to sort patient material that
can be at risk give risk to the operator
the microchip of the maxwell title is
disposable is closed and is aerosol free
and these really help to avoid carryover
or risk of infection of the operator
after sorting with the maxwell title
we have
taken the same cells
and then add them in culture and here we
use the b cell expansion kit
that is a specific kit developed with
span polyclonal b cells
via cd40 ligand multimer
and also il4 cytokine
this combination really helped the b
cells to expand and then also to start
producing antibodies
what we have observed here
is that
the
antigen specific so spy specific visas
in culture expanded nicely after 14 days
and also
they were able to produce
igg specific for spike
basically after 14 days we have
collected a supernatant a measure with
an elisa-like system
the presence of igg
antibodies against the spike so not only
the the antigen specific cell expanding
in culture but they were also able to
produce specific antibodies proving that
these cells isolated with our protocol
we are alive and active and functional
and could potentially be used for
antibodies generation
however there is also an alternative to
sorting that is the magnetic enrichment
it is possible to use um sask of two b
cell magnetic enrichment via using a
second labeling with anti-pe microbit
and then run the cells through the
column
what you collect as positive fraction
will be then the antigen-specific b
cells
as you can see from the data in this way
you can obtain a very nice
40 times full enrichment of the
population of need the purity is not as
good as resorting
but is possible in this way to have a
high enrichment of the rich population
which is a very rare population usually
and then you can further do serial
dilution to isolate the single cells in
single clones
from the first of every it's also
possible to collect to um to buy all
this
reagents and also to have a clear
protocol in the data sheet by buying the
uh specific sask of 2b cell kits we
offer a sas curve to be selling this kit
that includes all the panels of antibody
i showed you before
and either the spike protein or the rbd
protein
instead for the magnetic enrichment we
offer sask of two b cell microbial kit
that can also be uh either for spike or
rbd and is composed of streptavidin the
protein and also antip microbeads
and now let's step into the therapeutic
antibody discovery
so in order to develop therapeutic
antibodies for example for covid19
treatment but also for cancer treatment
many steps have to be followed first you
need to define a target invalidated then
you need to discover which antibody
binds this target
then you have to produce the antibody in
a stable system once they are produced
you want to test them functionally to
make sure that they are optimal for
their purpose for example as i showed
before if they are neutralizing or they
can be used to recruit other cells or
optionalization or other function very
often antibodies are also engineered to
make them more stable to make them more
specific and more
more able to to bind a target with high
affinity and so on
and finally you want to select the right
candidate that can be using clinical
testing so you will have to do some
preclinical data and if then the product
goes into them into the clinical trials
you will have a candidate
drug that can eventually after all the
phases of clinical trial become
a final pharmaceutical product
in the second part
of the webinar i will therefore focus on
the antibody discovery
but invite you also to follow other
webinar available in our military
biotech
database that explain
other steps such as the functional
analysis of antibody candidates that you
can see here
so let's look now about what is the
process for antibody discovery
so what is the good antibody candidate
and how do you find it
so ideally you can assume that subject
exposed to a certain pathogen might be
able to develop an immune response to it
including specific antibodies able to
eliminate pathogens and you might want
to start from these
individuals
to collect antibodies that could be
effective against the pathogen
in covenanting for example
this search was done looking into the
serum of convalescent individuals able
to neutralize the virus and recover from
the disease
therefore most of the approaches to
identify antibodies suitable for therapy
look for natural antibodies present in
the body of human or animals they have
been encountered either with the
pathogen or with an immunization to that
pathogen
however an unbiased approach is also
possible by starting uh to use by using
libraries of synthetic genes so the
scope of the antibody identification is
to determine the sequence
of the antibody in order to clone it in
an in vitro system able to express the
antibody in culture for a mass
production
but how do you practically identify the
antibodies sequence
antibodies are found in the serum but
it's basically not possible to just
isolate the immunoglobulin proteins from
the blood and understand the exact
sequence just starting from the protein
purification although some advancement
has been done in this direction using
max
mass spectrometry but the only way to
properly identify a specific antibody
and its sequence is actually to identify
the b cells that can produce it or the
plasma cells
and then sequence their genome in order
to determine the sequence of the
antibodies that they produce
but how can you find and isolate
b cells or plasma cells
so let's have a look at the typical
development path and
compartmentalization of b cells and
plasma cells the b cells develop in
several steps as you can see here is
quite a complex maturation process
and then they can become either
follicular b cells homogeneous or b
cells and they will enter eventually in
the lymph node at this different step of
this complex differentiation they might
develop into plasma cells and the plasma
cells are then secreting the antibodies
but where can you find these cells and
how can you really isolate them and
which are the one appropriate for
therapeutic antibody discovery
so first of all you need to see where
the cells are located if you want to
work with patients so or in material
from human you cannot imagine to collect
it from from certain tissue because it
would not be also ethically allowed it
would be much easier to access the
the cells in the blood
and as you can see here a lot of the
first step of the
b cells method should happen in the bone
marrow then the cells goes into the
blood then they go again in the lymph
nodes so they're again not accessible
and in some cases they are in blood like
in the case of plasma blast but only for
a very short window of time to between 7
and 14 days after immunization after
contact with the infectious disease
infectious agent
and
at one point they become memory be they
are in the blood and they persist also
in the blood for long as we've seen for
the example subscribe to but then
eventually enter again in the bone
marrow to become long-leaf plasma cells
plasma blasts also can be found in the
blood but also in this very narrow
window so it's actually not very easy to
find
uh cells a b cell specific for a certain
antigen
unless you really look for memory
bissell in the blood
plasma cells have a very short window in
which are present and also the second
problem is that plasma cells they don't
express anymore
the bc are on the surface so they cannot
be fish out by using antigens
so that's why most of the people focus
on the isolation of memory b cells from
blood also after every each single step
of maturation b cells improve the
binding efficiency to the antigen
therefore it's very important to take
them at the very end of the development
in this illustration that i taken from a
very informative review that i mentioned
here below you can see how specific
antibodies can be identified stain
starting from memory b cells indeed the
driving idea of these approaches is that
the b cells need to be isolating single
clones of identical b cells or producing
the same type of antibodies
once the clones are then separated the
single step is to identify the ones able
to produce antibodies specific for the
target antigen and indeed ideally
functionally active
finally it is necessary to sequence the
b cell clones to identify the antibody
sequence and then express it in a
different cellular system for max per
mass production
after the first isolation of business
there are mainly three ways to identify
single clones
on the left here is the sorting of the
single cells in separate wells and then
the culture on feeder cells in order to
collect supernatural to test the
antibodies of each clone
in the middle you see the they are the
option that is to fuse immediately the b
cells with an ebv in order to
immortalize them and then sort the
single cells into wealth
after immortalization the bin cells will
not need feeder cells anymore and they
could be able to um to replicate and
then stay in the in the well without
problems on the right side you see
another approach which is the direct
sequencing and cloning
that makes sense for example if specific
antigen is known and all the sort of
cells are antigen specific
this is the case of cavity 19 where
spike specific b cell can be sorted to
identify neutralizing antibodies against
the spike protein
this approach might not require single
cell sorting and culture but simply
single cell sequencing starting from the
population of energy specific b cells
here you can see an example of what we
offer as product and solution and
instrument to support the discovery of
therapeutic antibodies
so first you can start from the
preparation of the sample you can start
from blood but in some cases like cause
of cancer you might start from cancer
tissue coming either from patient or
from animal models
some users that want to work on human
samples they might wish to start from
different type of starting material and
some wish to directly separate the cells
from the blood so in this case the b
cells from blood and other they want to
step the furthest step of bbnc as
relation we have actually solution for
every of the solution also for different
type of staffing blood material
after the b cell separation uh with
their respective type of separation
systems
the b cells then can be analyzed using
uh flow antibodies and a flow cytometry
like the max wand then the b cells can
be cultured for expansion and yeah also
we offer some media media as i show you
before we have a business expansion kit
that works very nicely and also other
type of
reagents that can be very useful in b
cell
activation for example tlr ligands and
cytokines and also as mentioned the cd40
liga multi market
and finally another important step that
could be part of this workflow is the
sorting as i mentioned before the max1
title cell sorter is very ideal in the
case of fragile cells such as pieces
because it's very gentle to the cells
compared to normal
droplet-based waters and also in case of
infectious materials starting from
infectious diseases
a patient infected with infectious
agents
is ideal because it doesn't carry over
samples it doesn't allow aerosol and has
disposable cartridge
and then finally once the antibodies
been identified as mentioned before
there are many ways that they can be
screened and this will imply then that
they use also an isolation or other type
of cells for example nk cells foreign
adccsa
or um
dendritic cells or any other type of
antigen-presented cells for the
mlr assay and for that as i mentioned
before i will invite you to um look into
our website in our offer for all the
webinars for maintenance biotech that
can give you more information on how to
set up a safe for antibody validation
as you see i mentioned before we have
seen antibody discovery and also i
mentioned briefly about functional
testing of the antibodies
and unfortunately we are now at the end
of this session
but i wish you uh that you could also
look into our different uh
material available either in our website
also if you contact our ourselves
representative to really investigate
further uh which are the optional
solution that we offer for
antibodies discovery and validation
and i'm really happy
that you have been part of this webinar
thank you for your attention
thank you christina for your informative
presentation
joining us today for the live q and a
session is dr suzanne bietzka product
manager for b cell portfolio at miltoni
biotech we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay
let's get started looks like uh dr
andreoni may be having a little bit of a
hard time
some technical issues here
so let's see
susanna are you available
yes i am available
okay well as uh
as christina gets logged in and and can
figure out the audio maybe you could
answer a few questions for me would that
be okay yeah
sure no problem
okay let's see i will go ahead and ask
uh which are the variants of concerns
which are the variants of concern
available
so we of course have um the wuhan
variant because it's probably like the
most interesting especially for vaccine
studies because all our yeah vaccines
are based on this variance you know of
course this is like you know very
interesting for the b cell researchers
and then of course we have the spike
variant
and the delta variant of the spike
protein so that's what i wanted to say
and then also the uk variant and some
other mutations that aren't so common so
actually we have quite some things
available so everything that you know
usually people look into we have
available
okay thank you susannah the next
question
do you think that the sars cov2 pandemic
has caused a better general
understanding of the immune system and
could other diseases be understood
thanks to the sars kobe 2 study
oh that's actually a very nice question
so actually um
i think
this is like you know depends a bit on
whom you're asking so who you're talking
about so
i would say like in general in the
society i think everybody now is talking
about antibodies and b cells so even
like you know our grandparents that
never heard like you know of this like
story before so this is like really i
think a topic that was like you know
really like more fashion than everybody
it's like you know talking about
vaccinations and everything so this is
like i think really nice that this like
move more into perspective of the
general society
um
and i think like you know from the
research point of view that more and
more people are started now to work more
yeah interdisciplinary so that like you
know people before working just under t
cells or a specific topic also now
started to look into b cells and that we
started now to look into ah what are
those both cell types doing what it's
like you know the whole immune system
doing so really look into like you know
this you know how it works together so
this is like really something
that we i think
really
changed and
i think also that we learned like a lot
yeah
yeah about like you know how we can fast
like you know
use the immune system like you know as
christina said in the webinar how we can
use like antibodies also for cancer how
we can i cannot work faster so i think
it really pushed the field a bit so that
we can really like you know
use this like you know disease for you
know maybe also like in how we react to
future pandemics i hope i think of
course that nothing is happening but
um i think this really is like you know
push to the whole field
all right thank you again susannah looks
like uh christina is still having
trouble getting connected and well we're
just i'll just go ahead and continue to
ask questions to you and then later if
she can get logged back in perhaps
she'll answer them as well and uh
and if you think she might want to add
anything
yeah the next question
uh can you also analyze plasma cells and
plasma blasts with the system
oh yeah this is actually also like a
really good question because obviously
like you know all of us know now that
plasma cells are those cells of the
immune system that produce actually the
antibodies in high quantity so it's like
you know really crazy they're like
little factories producing the
antibodies
and the problem is just with the plasma
cells that they just produce the
antibody so they don't have this b cell
receptors on the surface anymore so you
cannot yeah actually detect if those
plasma cells are producing then
antibodies against your antigen so like
you know for instance you're looking
into the spike protein so you cannot
really have the plasma cell then it
being attached
to your protein and selected by that and
look into it by that so then you would
rather have to go you know culture them
and look what antibodies they're
producing but of course we have this
subset of plasma blasts that are like
you know in between this activated or
memory b cells and then you know become
differentiate into the plasma cells this
we can still look into because they have
still the antibodies or the b cell
receptors or the antibody that is bound
to the surface of the b cells they still
have it and so we could still look into
them and look if they are binding than
the spike protein
and then also you could just add to the
panel
then the
cd38 marker because that's like you know
main interesting marker for the plasma
cells
and when uh so you could just like
easily exchange like for instance the
igm because this is probably that not so
interesting anymore because that's like
more an antibody that's produced in yeah
in a natural
you call like usual natural antibody and
not just not so evolved and not so
mature and um
so usually when you look into plasma
cells you're not interested in that
anymore so you could just like exchange
this igm anti-igm antibody apc against
like cd38 apc so this would be like you
know easy exchange so i think that
wouldn't be a problem
even like the compensation could be the
same so this is like yeah it could be
done partially
uh thanks again suzanne it looks like we
have uh christina back with us so um i
will ask the next question here can you
hear me
christina
i i thought i think we have her back
let's see i will go ahead and ask the
next the next question and if either of
you want to answer that'd be fine but
just whichever way you want to do that
can one detect or sort antibodies
created via naturally acquired or
immunized immunity is there a
distinction
[Music]
if there's a distinction
that's actually like you know really
good question
um i don't know how you would like you
know like do
so you can like you know isolate both
and like you know you know like get your
antibody of both systems
and you can of course like you know
sequence then the the genes
and then see like you know how maturated
they are so how high the mutations in
the v region so these are variable
regions that usually change when you
like have something that is like really
adapted to an antigen and usually like
when this is like you know longer
process when you're sick and you have
natural exposure usually like this is
like you know higher
yeah the
regions are higher maturated higher
mutated so by this you could like
differentiate but
you know not really looking onto the
antibodies
probably and also like to the b cell so
this is like you know really tricky
i would say if you have like you know
proper immunization it would also like
probably look the same that's why you
get like you know the boost so
tricky there you would you really need
to like you know do some some
distinctive research and do a lot of
sequencing and and checking like you
know
maybe genes
yeah that's very interesting um because
we you know b cells and t cells are b
cells and t cells so i i'm interested to
learn yeah
if that works okay let's see
i'm trying to find an okay so the next
question what is the minimum of b cells
needed for the cell culture with the
improved medium at the moment
so um
actually oh i don't really know that i
think i have in mind something around
700
but um we have like a nice uh protocol
that we wrote someone really like
specified that on cell norms what do you
have to pipette and everything like just
really all the details
so um
it would be like you know the best like
maybe you can like also like you know
send it around later when i think like
you know when we compile information
maybe somebody also wants to get like
you know some additional information so
then maybe we can also like
add a link there because then i think
yeah it was like around like 700 you
know like for visas going higher is
always like possible but uh you know
like just having a few b cells in
culture is always a bit tricky
and uh therefore it's always like a bit
uh
yeah but
yeah i'm always asked this question how
low can we go but i think like you know
it was like around that cell number that
we tested and uh yeah for details please
have a look on our home page there we
have the protocol for
the b cell cultivation and also like in
the specific case with sorting the cells
before but we also try to you know send
the email then around later
all right thank you again susannah let's
see
i'm going to ask if we've got a few more
questions here and hopefully uh
christina can get her audio fixed i
think she can hear us but we can't hear
her so i apologize for any inconvenience
i'm so glad you're here to answer these
questions
okay next question let's see is b-cell
pre-enrichment needed
ah special period when needed yeah
needed not so you can like really do it
like you know from pbmc so we tested
both
of course and
yeah the huge difference actually is
that you're much faster and get of
course like higher purities than you
pre-enrich your b cells so this is like
really something that is like you know
depends a bit on
how
yeah pure you want to have it so do you
really mind if there are like you know
some other not specific b cells in there
so um
we usually like to be like you know very
specific and very pure so that's why we
added the pre-enrichment and also for
people that want to maybe like look into
different subsets
of cells so not not only b cells so like
as we said like you know we also looked
into the t cells and used the very same
samples because also in the beginning it
was not so easy to get like you know the
patient samples and then we started
first to actually isolate b and c cell
from the very same donor from the very
same blood sample and so by that we got
like most of the information out that
was possible
and so i would recommend it because i
think it's always like you know good
that you are pure but
if you don't need it of course uh you
can just also just go from your pbmc
stock
all right great thank you again see
we've got a couple more questions what
is the advantage of tetramers over
single protein conjugation
oh yeah
it's uh one of their favorite like you
know you say questions
um
so when you have like the tetramere it's
like
of course
um yeah bigger you have like more sides
where the antibodies or where the b
cells like can bind with the b cell
receptor
and that's of course like you know the
more antigen you have the better
representation representation is there
and the better the
cells are bound there so that's why you
usually like to use the tetrameter
that's
actually very common technique
in the the b cell field that you use
like this tetra mass then you have like
more binding site because actually
usually like you know
the protein is like otherwise like you
know really like tiny
and you know it's not so easy like you
know to see them like you know in the
flow analysis also like for the
isolation it's like you know
it doesn't work that good and the more
binding sites you have the higher
ability there is so the better binding
actually is happening and that's like
also like you know something then you
have more specific binding there
um and that is always like you know
something that you want to have because
then you don't have like you know
unspecific binding and some you know
like cells that you actually don't want
to have like you know in your specific
culture so or like you know in your
experiment and that's why this is always
recommended and that's why we also do
the double staining so that you on top
of this tetramerization have like also
another signal
in the cytometer so that you can really
see your specific b cells that are
antigen specific because there's always
like such a you know low low number you
know we we're talking about 0.1 to 0.5
of the b cells but uh already like so
few
in the whole uh pbmc fraction and that's
why
this is like always like a good option
to use that
all right thank you again suzanne it
looks like we have uh christina back
with us i'm so pleased
this was the setting of the headset
sorry it didn't work
that's okay you know i think we're all
used to the technical issues you know of
this pandemic time so i will go ahead
and move on and you all both feel free
to answer as you you know as you please
so the next question can the tetramer
system be used also in mouse models
okay so if you don't mind jumping just
in this question
been faced a few times already um so
basically in principle yes
so
the protein um the spike protein or rbd
protein of course it belongs to the
virus right and a mouse can amount of
immune response a b cell response with
this response against antigen uh from
from a virus from a
for a
from a foreign
agent that comes into the body so in
principle yes in fact
there are models used to uh to to study
the vaccination um
in mice so you can basically take
a normal vaccine that is produced now uh
for carbon 19 and then in uh injected in
myosin and cmu response what is uh not
really value established i think now
there are some models coming but it was
never a good uh system was to have the
mouse as a model for infectious disease
of the virus
um but in terms of immunity that's
possible so based on that basically you
can actually stimulate
a b cell with any antigen um and i mean
in a sense you can stimulate the whole
b-cell pool in in a mammalian food any
antigen and and in this way also if you
have immunized a mouse with a spike
protein then you would be able to detect
the um
yeah the the b cell specifies that
protein using tetramer system so if you
inject the spike with a vaccine then you
can also detect that we have not tried
this in-house but we know of some
vaccine company that tried that we have
some collaborators that did it actually
with our citroen system and uh is
working quite well the difficulty is
that you have to also really think about
the immunity of the mouse because it's
different and the human the immune
response might be slightly different you
cannot get so many cells from the blood
you will probably look at splenocytes
and so the ratio of cells is different
right you have much more b cells in the
spleen so probably you have to
re-titrate the system and of course also
you cannot use the panel of antibody we
suggested because those are for human so
our kit would not work you need to
redesign the panel for mouse
ah interesting all right thank you
christina the next question here why are
assays for detection of immunity against
stars kobe 2 not prevalent
so
i think this question um i mean it's
very general i'm not sure if i'm
him correct maybe the person can
write another comment if once um
so
of course
to measure uh immunity against subscribe
to or immediate against the vaccine uh
you would mainly
look at the antibodies production in the
blood that's what you know a lot of
vaccine companies are doing to to detect
if the vaccine is working
but of course the cellular immunity is
also very important
and
so far but but but the problem is that
cellular immunity is more complex to
analyze and honestly also more expensive
because you you know to do an elisa on
on antibodies in the serum is much
easier and cheaper than to analyze cells
in the blood however we hope also with
our system that we provide something
already west under dies and also
relatively affordable that can also
become eventually a standard procedure
in
in measuring in monitoring and screening
vaccinated or infected individuals
in maybe in big studies
so it's i think the reason why this is
not done yet is because first because
there was kind of an understanding
initially that
antibody response is the only thing that
counts which is not true
now with with many studies has been seen
that for example this response is very
important also memory b so now more and
more
studies will probably try to look into
the cellular immunity as well
uh because as we know it could be that
there and it's not necessary to do so
many boosts like third fourth dose of
vaccine maybe is enough to measure the
visa response and the teacher response
to really know if people are really
protected and to do that of course you
have to set up a safe
all right thank you christina looks like
we have one more question here
could i apply this antigen-specific
lymphocyte technique on
cancer-associated complex glycan
sometimes the real glycan structure is
hard to synthesize
so suzanne do you want to add something
here i have some idea but
yeah i'm also like not 100 sure like you
know
what it's like you know um
so you me
so let me rephrase it so i think the
question means
if we could do that on like you know
isolated antigens like you know like not
synthetic once
um this is like really tricky because
like you know you always have to couple
your antigen then to like you know
somehow
via
you know usually you did it like you
know we did it by a beauty into like you
know pe because we have to some how make
it visible in the flow cytometer so this
is like you know a bit tricky but of
course you could
couple it directly to your glucan that's
like you know is possible so i think
like you know
that is like a big bit tricky and you
would have to like you know really test
a bit around but like you know in theory
that should be possible
but
as you know when you don't produce
something like you know in a like you
know specific way it's not like you know
as reproducible as when you like you
know isolate something from like fresh
material you know as i did that for like
you know i worked with parasites so we
also did like parasite lysates and tried
to do some
you know antibody and b cell selection
on that and never worked as good as when
you're synthesizing your proteins
so i think this is like really tricky
all right thank you so much
looks like that's all we have time for
today um thank you christina do you have
any final comments for the audience
before we go
thank you i'm sorry for the technical
mistake uh problem but yeah i believe
suzanne was
the great perfect person to answer all
of your questions in the beginning
uh yeah she might have mentioned uh in
one of the first questions that is
really a good opportunity now um with
the studies of task of two to
investigate more the immune response
specifically b cell response and i think
this is opens a lot of revenues for more
more studies and and more understanding
not just of viral infection but also of
cancer and the last question was
actually indeed very interesting because
this is also where we would like to move
uh in the future not just for
therapeutic antibodies for viral
diseases but also
for the cancer research so we are happy
to
get in contact with you i thought there
were also a few technical questions
maybe we are not able to answer today
but if you want to yeah be in contact
with us and
get in touch we will be happy to help
you to set up the best
system for your study whether they are
for first of two any other viral disease
or even for cancer
so thank you very much for your
participation
well thank you again dr christina
conforti angrioni for your time today
and for your important research thank
you also to dr suzanne biepke for
answering so many questions we would
also like to thank labrutz and our
sponsor miltoni biotek for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye